hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem lätz battle
twilight vor ist irgendwas zusammen mit
der kev wir sind zusammen mtv hallo
hallo
[Musik]
diese ganzen leute machen wird ob
smiling des teams paco phoenix keine
media.de nah genug place black sonic hd
und dirk f und luca dass wir sind alle
sachen die bei uns in der kiste sind und
wir sind in einer twilight forest map
ich springe ich schon so ein bisschen
montag könnte ein bisschen was sehen das
ist dann extra plugin oder motto 'der
keine ahnung und es geht genau in einer
minute dreißig los nord macht gleichen
countdown und dann heißt es 30 minuten
lang haben wir so eine grace periode das
heißt wir suchen uns dann diamanten und
alle möglichen sachen unter der erde und
damit wir uns gerne schwerter machen
können usw geiler an dieser map ist weil
das halt eben so eine spezielle mod
entwicklung ist dass hier alles anders
aussieht das heißt anderem ob es gibt
hier in der original map auch
theoretisch post mops die sind glaube
ich aber jetzt hier deaktiviert
ansonsten gibt es generell überall
irgendwelche effekte gegenständen die
auch anders funktionieren also vom
grundprinzip ist es trotzdem minecraft
aber halt ein bisschen anders war als
andere items und mal was neues dabei ist
ja genau
also die mob es sind halt keine mops
hinzugefügt worden außer also keine
extrem 9 die hier auch mit enthalten
sind die wurden zwar zugefügt allerdings
hat neun ob solche sachen die neue
bossgegner und so was alles hat er
ausgemacht meinte er
ja genau damit das nicht allzu schlimm
und schwer wird weil wir dass halle und
ich kenne und ich sehe das auch gerade
zum ersten mal diese welt hier und alles
und die sache ist auch die das ist jetzt
erst mal 30 minuten freie wahl haben was
wir tun was wir machen und danach geht
es direkt los menschen so ist es uns
hier habe die gedanken gemacht dass wir
um die produktivität zu erhöhen und
gleich am anfang erstmal direkt wenn das
heißt luca wird einfach unter die erde
gehen und bisschen rum graben und ich im
laufe oben rum und die offensichtlichen
kisten beta steht ja sonst die sachen
schon mal nehmen wenn wir wollen
radio ist und ich hab dich ganz so sein
sagt zack zack zack
okay da hab ich vielleicht nicht das
zweite auch noch kriegen das gold steht
ist noch übel schnell kaputt da kannst
du auch mal was das brauch ich weiß
nicht das waren jetzt plötzlich schon
mal im bett druck passiert jetzt geht
muss genau so und aus jahren hast du
hast du schuhe
ich habe schon dann ich hab das wetter
wieder eingelegt welche schwert das eine
welche seiten welches eine kleine ahnung
hatte ich ganz einfach unter scheiße
schaffen wir das überhaupt diesen tag um
mein gott ich hätten allerdings zu harte
höhe
ich bin da man ja warte ich versuche
gerade irgendwie im weg war das internet
uns gerade ich laufe jetzt schnell los
habe ich die ersten offensichtlichen
kisten abgleich ja mach mal
ich gehe jetzt versucht irgendwie unter
die erde zu gehen so haha ich glaube
macht gibt es überhaupt offensichtliche
kisten ich glaube nicht ich glaube auch
nicht deswegen gehe ich erstmal direkt
unter die erde
ich kann ja nicht ich hätte vielleicht
ein hier ist ein häuschen deswegen hatte
ich mir auch erst mal ein bisschen holz
genau und ich schaue hier wo komme ich
ihm verlangte auch in die pilze und so
was zu holen damit wir uns suppen machen
können und 24 grad holz ich habe hier
haus gefunden wie supporten sich hinter
als wäre ich jetzt verstehe ich nicht ja
ich habe die kiste gefunden und was da
drin hat nur kartoffeln fackeln ist dick
so waßmann wir brauchen vernünftige
schwerte wir brauchen auf jeden fall
eisen als heißt man sich erst mal das
wichtigste ich würd sagen wir trennen
uns beide erstmal dann wie gesagt nach
den 15 minuten finden wir uns dann und
dann nie gemacht was ich mache mir
trotzdem eine spitzhacke
sicherheitshalber auch wenn sie nur aus
holz ist hast du einen cocktail wo bist
du dich hab im werk table wo bist du ein
stück weg ich bin am spot direkt einmal
komme ich noch kurz zurück sind 100
meter ich habe mir jetzt m4 normal holz
gesammelt und dann kannst du mir kurz
dreistein abbauen dann kann ich mir
wenigstens nur lastspitzen wo bist du
ich komme ich sehe da zwei leute auf dem
baum ok ich sehe dich bestimmt hat
stehen bleibt stehen einfach als
teilnehmer heute kommt hier nicht ad hoc
dass die anderen ja okay gut okay hier
kämpft und pilze hast du stein oder
kannst möglichen abbauen
du hast doch selbst eine spitzhacke nee
ich hatte mir nur ein spieltag die habe
ich die gegeben was soll da warte ich
mich eine spitzhacke hin so dass eine
spitzhacke holz ja dann brauchst du als
steinadler das holz so ich habe die
halterin gespielt also jetzt soll ich
die workbench ab ja ich gehe jetzt auch
erstmal eine höhere hier ist auch schon
direkt natürliches kohle oder erhöhen
damit ich so wenn du einfach
irgendwelche kisten oder irgendwie
höhlen keine ahnung damit wegen wie
diamanten ach so ich habe jetzt auch
schon kaktus und irgendwelche blumen
gefunden und doug ist aber das war das
war ganz witzig diese im das war so eine
ruine und da habe ich mich einfach durch
den boden gegraben weil ich im das holz
haben wollte und dann war da so die
kugel nicht okay eigentlich zu
geburtstagen da ne kiste
ich bin gerade in seinen fakten
höhlensystem das ist nicht meine würde
ist das normal dass die monster aus sind
ja gut problem ist also ich find here
ich finde ja keine richtige höhle
ich habe zwar schon kohle und zwar wenn
du bist mir kommt ist nur durch die
gefühle kommt für wichtig die freien
auch direkt wo willst du hin gelaufen
denn gerade aus weiter gelaufen dass
born ist 160 meter von ihr entfernt ist
aber noch ganz geradeaus und erwarte ich
suche mir meine eigene würde dann kann
man es auch gleich irgendeinem spawn
treffen
ach so soll ich denn er hört nicht auf
oben weiter lange ja du kannst auch in
der höhle genau ich sehe dich nicht ich
ist das geil hier gibt es andere erfolge
ich habe ihn jetzt zwei light fanta das
heißt ich habe jetzt ohne witz was sind
das ist ja das ist natürlich ein erfolg
würde die knallharte hand habe ich die
knaller ins kommt herunter oder das gold
gold bringt das aber nicht viel erwartet
hier ist noch mal was die community
keller ich wette mit
leider nicht wieder so ein haus soll ich
mir runter kommen jetzt einfach ja kommt
in die hülle wir brauchen definitiv klar
wir brauchen definitiv erst mal eisen
diamanten und sowas als er sagt habe ich
gefunden ja dann brauch ich hab kohle
kohle brauchen wir gar nicht also ich
hab wirklich genug kurzum verblendung
war das ja ich hab kohle deswegen muss
nicht abbauen ich muss mir erst mal eine
eisen praktikum also ich weiß nicht
vielleicht kann man hier was aus dem
fall auf einen vergifteten kartoffeln
eine breite schon gefunden
vielleicht kommt erstmal fackeln warte
ich mir das mal fackeln so zwei eisen
sind leider nur dann hast egal
im fackel habe ich auch gefunden in der
kiste ja fackel habe ich jetzt auch
gerade elf stück nur aber besser als
nichts sind dass er es für blöcke die
ich ja noch was hinten versteckt hat
kann ihre hole ich auch mal was kosten
hierfür blöcke ja das frage ich mich
auch die ganze zeit es gab ja gesagt es
gibt diese ironwood blöcke achso er wenn
du hast du dann immer am besten noch im
wohl damit wie geil ist das denn
das sind hölzer wenn du die kaputten aus
kriegst du steaks raus und gold tatsache
gold habe ich jetzt einfach mal
mitgenommen und ich bin direkt hinter
ihr
ich glaube ich bin kurz davor mich
einfach noch für 16 runter zu graben
er macht das mal ich schaue ihn nur an
der oberfläche kurz war hier ist teils
zuversichtlich
ich nehme auch die fackeln wieder mit
also kohle brauchen wir wirklich nicht
oder was hast du ne cola hab ich
wirklich genug ich nehme noch mal eins
mit so ok ich glaube ich jetzt runter ob
wir sehen uns gut und dem kompletten
einfach mit oder diesen gang siehst du
mich dann gebt einfach alteisen und
sodann rutschig da schon musste aber im
wasser lang gelaufen ich bin da diesen
gang hinter dir da wo du gard fackeln
weggenommen was sollte es eigentlich
sehen ich sehe dann nicht jetzt meine
beim kämpfen erlaubt noch mal wieder
zurück muss man mit schwertkämpfen das
hört sich so geil hat ja hier kommt
nichts raus
ich laufe jetzt acht da bist du dann bei
dem baum okay ich komme
wer was für ein baum ich sehe einen
namen alles klar ich bin unter der erde
ich glaub mal runter stumpfen ja machen
ich hoffe ich auch auf den langsamen
hier sogar gegen zwölf habe ich jetzt
nicht einfach in den oasen gefunden
direkt beim stumpf unterbau wie geile
krasser kcal
ich habe bradstreet brauchen wir
eigentlich nicht das ist mega reisen
fällt das sind fast schon zehn eisen
okay das geil hier geht es schon richtig
ab was machen wir uns dann aus dem eisen
nicht wer erstmal eigentlich für ein
charity jetzt auch noch als schwert und
nachrüstung auf jeden fall sind
natürlich die höhe schoss
ich bin doch nur zwölf grad erfroren
oder als organ irgendwo dazwischen
brauchen wir nicht hinnehmen wollen wir
nicht nur eisen und diamanten ist das
wichtigste
okay das finde ich bin wie eine geile
idee mit diesen hölzern dass man ihre
steaks findet sind einfach in der höhle
ich habe jetzt wieviel hast du 12.12
okay ich habe
8 da war ich gleich schon mal anrufen
dann kann man schon mal sachen machen
oder es wird ja echt könnte ich hier mit
dem diamanten habt ihr wirklich hier auf
dieser niedrigen höhe sind
du kannst dich auch für 16 einfach mal
rum graben da wär ich dafür dass wir auf
unterschiedlichen höhen graben und den
unterschieden in richtung gehe ich
einfach kurz mal hoch dann mach das mal
was du dich und dann wieder acht sich
auch sturm zu untergraben
gerade jetzt noch richtig viel eisen ja
bin ich jetzt aufhöre 60 richtig also
ist hier attacke lustig ist es ja wenn
man weil es gibt hier und gillett ist
dann darf ich habe schon komische blöcke
von diesen grün komisch keine ahnung ich
muss mir auf jeden fall gleich wie heißt
das ding noch mal ein schwert man blau
und gold und kupfer hätte ja gleich an
stirbst du stirbst du warst so sehe ich
hab's geschafft aber ich werd dann macht
den eisen schwert oder mach erst mal
offen das jetzt wahrscheinlich bisschen
stein ja habe ich mache mir erst mal ach
so ja stimmt ach crafting tablett ich
dir geben können ich habe den server
verkehr gut ich war hier wirklich weiter
für elf rum und ich als präsident und
weist er da wurde nach gut dass ich eine
kohle mit genau habe ich wenigstens acht
reisen darunter so naja gekommen da muss
ich lange attacke wenn wir zwei
diamanten sind das jetzt schon immer
gern erinnern die ammann schweiz hatte
ich schon mega vorteil ich weiß gar
nicht wenn das ja so eine special map
ist wer weiß ob man tatsächlich hier
diamanten findet auf dieser höhe
ich weiß nicht wie man da auch schon
leise und matt stone gefunden also
eigentlich müsste ist der fall sei nur
irgendwie doof dass er jetzt nicht
dieser komischen fest untergegangen sind
nenner war schon richtig richtig geile
sache glaubt man muss auch ein bisschen
an der oberfläche lang laufen soll ich
vielleicht noch mal hoch gehen oder was
ja dann kann man am besten zu mir deine
erste rate ich dann schauen wir im jahr
kommen du einfach zurück ich habe ja den
ofen ich habe wieder eisen das heißt
einer muss ja hier kurz bleiben bis das
fertig gebraten ist okay wobei ich habe
vorher noch kohle da wo du runter
gegangen bist mit der treppe da bin ich
habe ja noch einmal sechs stück gefunden
ich sehe einen namen auf jeden fall
schon mal das ist gut so hätte die tv
mit einer webpage zugebaut also sollte
da keiner kommen
[Musik]
okay ich habe wir haben dann insgesamt
27 also willst du mir ich mache schon
mal zwei schwerter okay wenn auch
manchmal ein eisen spitzhacke machen
ich habe da ist er hingeschmissen
nämlich machst du noch eine spitzhacke
also schwitzt kann ich machen aber dann
habe ich aber ab nach oben und die meine
hast du auch rettung
welche fächer bei zwei tnt ja ich kann
ja auch noch meine tnt gebe ich komme
dann war da nicht zu versuchen ruhe zu
finden und dann allerdings so warte ich
mach uns meine kiste ich hab gar nicht
so viel holz [ __ ] ich hab alles mache
ihnen eine kiste oder so damit wieder
ein paar sachen einlagern können dann
nachher schon können waypoint oder was
wie hier in webos setzen ja kann man
irgendwo verstecken warte ich mal
wayport ich glaube schon mal einfach
keine zeit verlieren hast du denn die
kiste hingeschmissen aber ich ihn
gemacht kiste okay jetzt habe ich eine
kiste
ich habe mir den weg dorthin gesetzt
jetzt also mach aber den eingang am
besten zu irgendwie dass da keiner
hingegen kommt mit erde kann nicht zu
machen
ja mach einfach unsere fackel weg ja ich
habe trotz berrys was ist denn das leder
nicht sexy sein ich probier's einfach
mal aus gold ich weiß nicht wofür gold
aus dem torch paris kannst du fünf
fackeln machen
keine kohle gebraucht wie fünf fackeln
ja wenn du holz und torch perry machst
kriegst du in 5 fackelt ausgeguckt ach
so ja egal denn hängen häuschen passt
irgendwelche pilze für mich ich habe die
anderen pilzen bronze naja dann kommen
einfach rein und gibt mir die und sucht
nach rote pilze die man besten alle
deine sachen die erstmalig draufstand
verwalte ich dass er uns ein bisschen
zeit ich habe ein paar braune gefunden
wo waren das jetzt hier schon so oft
erlaufen ich finde es nicht mehr
und am besten denn jetzt gegen mops
kämpfst du hast noch entscheiden
das eisen schwer hier bist du drin ja
nicht erwarten was können wir mal mit
denen machen brauchen aber ich habe
keine geschenke
diamanten getränke ich hab so ich komme
jetzt und hier gibt ja alles was ich
brauche
ihr habt
justin ich das nicht dass nicht das
nicht dass nicht das nicht dass nicht
das nicht zackig auch nicht so viele
hier
und ja apple gleich selber ok musste
passen
ich mache wieder zu oben ja ich mache
mir schon mal ein bisschen rüstung aus
den eisen wasser ist oder ich suche
einfach noch weiter reisen er du kannst
dir notfalls dann für mich auch dann
wirst du machen ich komme ja ich mache
uns einfach ein paar sachen sucht uhr am
besten in welche kisten oder pilze am
besten und sowas damit will man immer
alles mit was nicht finde ja alles was
geil dass die attacke hat sich dafür
wieder ins bonner gefunden nämlich
kaputt machen
borner darf man eigentlich kaputt mache
das alles kaputt machen
also ich würde jetzt nicht was dagegen
sprechen sollte zugleich müsse
eigentlich schon die erste folge vorbei
sein aber ich würde sagen wir machen
erstmal so weiter wie bisher nur dass du
jetzt oben weiter suchst hat sich alles
ein bisschen anders entwickelt sich
weiter und wir treffen uns dann fünf
minuten verändern dann einfach mal hier
unten und teilen ihre schatten auf die
haben sich keine mühe gemacht die
hütchen zu ändern da ich hab's gefunden
den turm ok ok dahin soll ich nicht
sprechen ich glaube schon
bostelmann unten am fuß ich sehe auch
den boss also kann sich auch einfach
rheingraben oder jetzt schon könnte auch
sein was aber auch sich auf nenne ich
das du stirbst nicht ändern die sachen
haben okay das wetter wird geändert das
ist gut
reisende von das ist auch schon mal
wieder neues ich bin drin
okay ich bin da unten wo es zwar ach so
ich bin in dem raum wo der kaktus ist
und ich hab die bibliothek gefunden mit
einer kiste die noch voll ist und was
ich alles drin eine ahnung papier
bücherregale sowas aber dann haben da
war kommt kontrast das ist schon wichtig
gewesen und noch eine kiste gefunden ist
wirkungsloser trank sofortige heilung
zwei eisenrose mit verzauberung also
somit verzauberung er besuch auf jeden
fall weiter darin und weil also gegen
geht den bus auf dem weg dass stella
wenn du in der infobox ist ja der boss
ist ja oben ich bin ja ganz unten habe
mich da rein kommt immer mehr gegner ja
passt auf jeden fall wenn sie dann noch
einfacher war auf jeden fall nicht
sterben das ist wichtig zur not ich
nehme noch gold mit vielleicht kann man
es dann noch eine gold ratio machen wenn
wir da nicht so viel haben vor
auf jeden fall sind wir ein bisschen
durch schnetzeln ich will aber meine
fackeln ja auch nicht von ball an der
egal fackelt erstmal egal wem sowas von
kohle ja ja ja ja das klar dann kann ich
jedoch ein bisschen ausleuchten
ok ich sehe hier ganz viele bücherregal
also ist es irgendwie so offensichtlich
sowie in hogwarts hier noch eine kiste
verzaubertes holzschwert schärfe 2 mit
verlangt der vergiftung machen wir ein
wurf fand der vergiftung groß
okay okay da kommt zurück
ich habe doch wieder diese leitungen
dort gefunden also fackeln haben auch
erst mal genug dann ist das geil ich
glaube das wird gut laufen aber ich weiß
nicht wie die anderen so drauf sind
also ich haben ja auch ganz geile sachen
also ich komme hier unten auch glaube
ich jetzt nicht weiter ist eigentlich
gehobenen richtung und wo zwei gegner
dann kommen am besten erst wieder
hierhin war hier ein point gesetzt wo
wir sind oder aber du wirst den weg
zurückfinden oder naja ok dann wird sie
am besten ihren freund und jeder noch
mal los schon versucht da noch mehr
sachen zu kriegen ok ich muss mir den
ausgang für das problem
gefunden das problem gefunden
killer ist eigentlich gar nicht so
schlecht so ich glaube ich erst mal
zurück er war schon zweimal gestorben
das andere team
ich glaube schon weiß klein bietet die
hab ich freue mich dann auch
einzelhändler war bei uns wahrscheinlich
nicht geboren aber irgendwie wir diese
noch nicht unter der erde fast für sich
wie weit weg bist du von spawn
200 gerade ich so an da unten ja ich
sehe dich gefunden kommst du nach dem
gezogen oder so ja ich komme gleich zu
denen ich glaube mir jetzt wieder
zufällig sind neben dem neuen eingang
glaube ich nicht wünschen in der
richtung weil du bist ich bin jetzt über
dir ja kommen einfach runter das seinen
gang den ich je gehabt habe
aber ich weiß nicht woran denen das
ertrunken
hier ist das hexenhäuschen alles klar
das heißt hier vorne war irgendwie ja
ich bin ich voll fälschlicherweise
eingelaufen ist hier müsste es
eigentlich jetzt links sein jawohl ich
hab es okay gut dann in der kiste sind
wir ganz viele sachen auf linz der
komplett hat geweint und der weizen
gedruckt und es tut bis zur totalen
gehabt noch kräfte an herz aber hier ist
wir müssen doch ausleuchten glaube ich
okay ja meine wie hast du dich wieder
richtig kurzfristig kommen gerade wieder
zu dir hin